[MUSIC PLAYING]
Happy Thursday, everybody.
Welcome to the Data
Science Hangout.
Hope you all are
having a great week.
If it is your first time
joining us today, hello.
Nice to meet you.
I'm Rachael.
This is for the data
science community
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing, and getting
to learn about what's
going on in the
world of data science
across different industries.
And so each week, we feature a
different data science leader,
as my co-host, to help lead
our discussion and answer
questions from you all.
So together, we're all
dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment
for everyone.
So I love when we can hear
from everybody, no matter
your level of experience,
or area of work,
or industry, each week.
It is totally OK to
just listen in as well.
But there's also three ways to
ask questions today and provide
your own perspective
on certain topics too.
So you could jump in by
raising your hand here on Zoom.
You can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put
a little star next to it
if you want me to
read it out loud,
if you're in a coffee
shop or something.
And then we also
have a Slido link,
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And our team should
be sharing that
in the chat in
just a second here.
But I do like to make sure
I tell everybody up front,
we share the recordings
of each session
to the Posit YouTube, also
the Data Science Hangout site.
So you can always go back and
rewatch or share with a friend.
I wanted to remember
to call this out too.
I wanted to specifically say,
if you are hiring right now,
feel free to share
that in the chat.
I never see that as spammy.
Sometimes people ask.
It's so awesome
to be able to hear
when rolls are filled by
people making connections here
in the hangout too.
Thank you so much,
Satish, for joining us
of the co-host today.
Satish is Senior Manager,
Pharma R&amp;D, IT at Janssen.
And I also wanted to
say thank you real quick
to the [? Atoris ?]
team, as well,
who are one of our full
service partners at Posit,
and they actually helped me
in scheduling today's session
with Satish.
So the [? Atoris ?]
team, if you want
to wave and say
hello to everybody,
or say hi in the chat too.
But, Satish, I'd
love to have you
introduce yourself and share
a little bit about your role.
Maybe also something you like
to do outside of work, too.
Yes.
I'm Satish Murthy.
I'm a part of Janssen R&amp;D IT.
I have responsibility primarily
for the R platform and soon
Python, as well.
It's a data science platform
to help our scientists run
through some reporting
for clinical trial,
whether it is top line
reporting, using grid
based computing.
It's an environment where
the traditional SaaS
is supported as well.
But there is an
accelerated growth
to how folks move on
to R at this time.
Thank you, Satish.
And just something that you
like to do outside of work, too.
It's always fun to hear
those from everybody.
Yeah.
There is a small hiking
place near my place,
near my house in Hillsboro.
I live in New Jersey.
And [? satellite ?] mountains.
For those of you who are close
by, that's where we hike often.
I do have a small dog, and
we with two kids I got out
with my wife anytime we can.
That's awesome.
So, Satish, as we
wait for questions
to come in from
everybody here, I'd
love to hear what
is something that--
this is a question we tend
to ask a lot of people.
What is something that you're
excited about in the year ahead
for your team?
Yeah.
As I indicated earlier, we
have the statistical program
and compute engine, what is
called SPACE, inside Janssen
to help our scientists.
One of the things that
we are looking forward
is to add capabilities
to this platform.
Because as the adoption grows,
as folks slowly start seeing
the power of R, and the open
source community support that
has really been the big
reason for us to adopt R --
because there is always a
learn from others' experience
as well, right?
So we are trying to see how
we can grow the R use case
and adopt it, number one.
And at the same time, enable
other tools and technologies
that our users are asking.
For example, we just introduced
the-- for some of the folks
who are wanting to
leverage Python,
we just added the
capability as well.
One of the things
that I'm proud of
is this is all in a
validated environment.
There are some challenges
that come along with it.
And we are partnering
with a [? Atoris ?] team
to help us with the
validation aspect of it.
Any GXP platform,
as folks might know,
there are two things in that.
One is a formal verification
that somebody traditional
in IT, like myself, would
be responsible for it.
Because it's crucial.
We have to build a
platform like this.
It's absolutely
essential that we
have to do repeated
install of this just
to prove what we installed
today is the same thing that we
can install tomorrow.
Because that will increase
the user confidence.
The other aspect of
it is the validation,
what we have installed.
Are the users comfortable
with the confidence
that what they
run today, they're
going to get the same results?
That is the formal verification
slash validation process,
that we are partnering
with [? Atoris ?]
to build some of
the capabilities
to support us in that effort.
As we continue to add
platforms, of course,
we have to keep up
with technology.
We have to keep up
with what is out there.
And some of the things
that I'm looking forward
is, traditionally, I have
to wear a development
hat at this time.
Some of the
platforms that we are
running out on
[? well seven, ?] as we think
about well seven
sunsetting, what
is it that we need to do to
build unrelated platforms?
What are the tools
that are available?
So that is what I'm looking
forward from that perspective.
Because that's an immediate
challenge, as folks might know.
We are-- [? well seven ?] is
going out of support by end
of this year with an additional
six months of extended support
formally by Red Hat.
But beyond that,
we have to think
about something--
this is a little bit
more tactical in nature.
But we have to go through
the entire process
of migrating to a new platform.
Thank you, Satish.
And I see Eric commenting
on the migrations, as well.
I was just going to ask
though, for someone like myself
who isn't in the
pharma industry,
and is not familiar with more
of the admin side of things,
what does having a validated
environment really mean?
Good question.
Validated environment, to me
is-- say, for example, pharma
and finance, as another example,
are regulated industries.
Correct?
What it means is any time a
health reporting agency comes
in and asks for
proof, we have to be
comfortable in saying that what
we ran a couple of days ago,
months ago, weeks
ago, or years ago,
we need to be in a
position to replicate
that entire environment as is.
So this goes through a formal
validation slash verification
process.
And this, in
traditional parlance,
is known as a GXP platform.
GXP is Good.
X will stand for clinical
practice, manufacturing
practice, lab practice.
So the verification validated
environment is often referred
to as a GXP environment.
So it is to build
confidence for the end users
that we serve in pharma.
It is for folks who
want to help deliver
patient care, which is crucial.
This is where the validated
environment-- or this
is what the validated
environment is, Rachael.
Thank you.
That's really helpful.
I didn't see there are a few
anonymous questions starting
to come in.
So I want to go
ask one over there.
But somebody had asked,
when talking about R,
we hear a lot from a data
science or engineering
perspective.
What do you think the
differences in thought
are from an IT perspective?
From an IT perspective.
Good question.
So the one advantage
that we have with R
is, as I mentioned earlier,
the power of open source,
where folks are contributing
to the R ecosystem as such.
So there are more and more folks
who are contributing to it.
It could be, at
the end of the day,
it's a traditional R
package that gets developed.
And often, what we are seeing
is, from an IT perspective,
there are some challenges
in reproducing this platform
as is.
Sometimes the frustration
that users have is,
hey, it worked
yesterday, why am I--
I tried the exact
same thing today.
Why am I having issues with it?
There are various reasons.
That's because, you
know, an underlying-- you
might be using version one
of one particular package.
But underneath that,
it will go and pull
certain dependencies, which
could be a function of time.
But there are tools
that are available
today to help us
with that approach.
In other words,
there is an R package
that folks are familiar
with, R, E, and B,
as an example, where you
can lock the versions.
We are also using Deposit
Package Manager as well,
to help us with
snapshotting capabilities.
And this is where IT can step
in, implement these tools,
so that users can be confident
that what they did today
they should be able to reproduce
the same environment tomorrow,
as well.
So Bill had asked, do
you have SaaS and R running
on the same validated server?
Is that server in the cloud?
And is that managed by an
external service provider?
Maybe I'll try and break this
up into multiple questions.
But Bill also asks, are
you having a hard time
finding a cloud hosting
service provider?
Who is doing that for you today?
Fair question.
One, we have completely
adopted a cloud, at least
inside Janssen.
Most of what we do, it is
with the cloud provider.
And we have a huge
investment with AWS.
We are partnering
with AWS, as and when
we would want new capabilities,
we do work with them
and see where they could help
us implement certain services
that we would need.
Now AWS might be ready, but then
our technology services team
would want to ensure,
because it's in the cloud,
that there are as several
security policies in place.
So we do have to go
through them to ensure
that the services offered by
any cloud service provider
is blessed by our security team.
That's how we work.
Number two, I think
the question was--
yeah, right.
So we run everything in AWS.
We do-- I don't want to call it
"a" server hosting SaaS and R.
Because end of the day,
from a tactical perspective,
these are different
assets, but it
is a part of the same ecosystem,
as I mentioned earlier.
That is the statistical and
program compute environment
which is a validated platform.
Think of it as a
platform consisting
of multiple components.
SaaS is one of them.
R is another.
100% validated at this time.
I don't know, Rachael, if there
was another question there.
Was there another?
No, I think that was great.
And Bill, feel free
to put it in the chat
if you wanted any more
context on that too.
I see, Eric, you just added
a question to the chat too.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure, it's great to virtually
see you again, Satish.
We've had some great
conversations in the past.
I really admire
what your team is
doing to push really
novel uses of tech.
I'd be curious if you could
tell this group more about how
containerization is helping
play a role in your cloud
deployments on AWS and how--
have you had any issues
integrating those technology
together?
And also how are you kind
of getting your data science
colleagues, your statistician
colleagues, on board
with using these platforms
that depend on these services?
If you could elaborate on that.
Certainly.
So I mentioned the AWS.
But one of the key
components of this
is containerization, Eric, as
you rightfully pointed out.
Yeah, I was waiting to--
I was hoping that somebody
would ask that question.
So everything in a
validated environment,
because the need or the ask
is to ensure repeatability
and reproducibility.
The only logical choice at
this time is containers.
We try to containerize.
Well, we have to.
It's not that we need to.
We have to containerize.
So the SPACE platform,
I have a responsibility
for the R part of it.
So I'm going to concentrate
a little bit more on that.
So one, users would
want to basically run
through their studies
using R. And how
do we do it is the question.
So we are using the project
workbench as our launch pad.
This is deployed on a
traditional EC2 instance,
and then either we
run ad hoc, just
to ensure for the
users this is possible.
This is the production platform.
But there is a logical grouping,
where our users would first
want to come and test it
in a development area,
and then move it into the
traditional QA and prod.
But the way they would first
test in the development area
is, number one, the entire
RStudio Posit Workbench
is containerized.
So we always ensure that we
try to keep up with the latest
release of Posit.
I think we are just one
release behind at this time.
And there are some unique
challenges around it.
The challenges are mostly
about the IQ, OQ, and the time
that it takes.
For example, it's
not just positive.
There are other vendors who are
helping us with this effort.
We have to go through a formal
process of vetting, validating,
and verifying.
So all of this takes time.
So typically, we lag behind.
That's one challenge
that we have.
Number two, because
we have containerized,
it gives our users
the capability
to test something
that is locked on
and be ensured that, again, from
a repeatability perspective,
containers are the only way
that will help them with that.
So first, we will go
through defining the process
and specifying the
requirements as to what really
needs to go into the container.
For example, if our users have
identified a set of workflows
that they would want, to help
them with the clinical studies
that they are looking
into, traditionally, it
will map to a set of--
if I have to wear
a tactical hat,
it is eventually going to
boil down to R packages.
The R packages that need to
make it into this container.
So this is where
we pretty much are
using standard
technologies and tools that
are used in the industry.
We have a Jenkins pipeline.
We are using the
passive workbench to--
sorry, the package
manager to lock down
versions of our
packages that we would
want to go into the container.
And there are some
business processes
that are defined as to what
should go into this container,
in terms of R packages.
Once we have defined, we run
through the build process
to create the container.
And we will verify it in the
traditional RStudio Workbench.
Once our users are
comfortable that, yes, this
is the workflow, this
fits of our model
and we don't see any issues.
That container is then blocked.
And then it moves into
the QA slash Prod area.
And that's where they
would run through the--
and that is what is
deemed as a validated run.
Anything that the users would
try out in their development
environment is a
prerequisite, but it is not
deemed as a validated run.
It is only when it is run
through the production
that it is deemed as validated.
In order to do that, not
all of these validated runs
behind the scenes will run
as a service account user,
because we want to
ensure that, number one,
no particular user runs
it in their environment
and it runs in a
service account.
Behind the scenes, we also have
the traditional EKS cluster,
and where we scale up and
launch these containers.
Thank you, Satish.
I was just going
to say in the chat,
I am definitely still learning
all of the AWS acronyms too.
So if anybody wants to
share those in the chat too,
that's really helpful.
One part of a question
earlier that we had missed,
and I think it would be really
helpful to cover as well
is, what role does a
partner like a [? Atoris ?]
play in facilitating
the AWS deployment?
OK.
We pretty much rely on
Tau We are partnering
with [? Atoris ?] mainly
for the validation
aspect of it, Rachael.
And what I mean by
that is, all of the R
packages that we
want to qualify,
[? Atoris ?] is
helping us with writing
the IQ, OQs that need to run.
For example, when we
build the container,
yes, we have a
list of R packages.
But how do we ensure that they
fit the user's requirements?
So one advantage--
one unique thing
that we have done
inside this is,
we do joint collaboration
when we build the container,
and we run through
the automatic process
of running through the IQ, OQ
steps that has been written
by the [? Atoris ?] team.
The advantage is, once you
go through the container
build process, one, we are--
as I mentioned earlier, we
are verifying, saying that these
are the list of our packages
that get installed.
But at the same time,
the scripts will
run during the build process,
which runs through these IQ,
OQ steps.
And at the end of the day,
it will generate a validation
report, where we go
through each and every IQ
step that has been written.
It could be Install
Package A, then
ensure that all of
the functionality
within that package
fits our requirements.
And this is where the
OQ part of it helps.
So we run through
the build process.
And then at the
end of the day, we
inspect the validation report.
Then we take a look.
Hey, did all of the
test cases pass?
If it failed, what
was the reason?
Is this because of an
underlying system dependency?
Or is this because some other
additional package that we
forgot needs to be installed?
Or is it simply because
there was a bug somewhere?
And we go through this process.
It's an iterative process.
This is where
[? Atoris ?] is basically
building the entire
IQ, OQ part of it
and taking responsibility
for the validation aspect.
That's great.
Thank you.
I want to jump over to-- and
I don't know if someody from
[? Atoris ?] want
to chime in as well.
I did want to give them the
opportunity, because they are
the ones who are writing this.
Yeah.
I would just say it
was, Satish, working
with you from the
beginning, getting
that design of the entire
pipeline worked out so
that it could all fit
within the container build,
that being an upfront
requirement of what
you wanted to see there.
But it's been a
close relationship
with Satish and
the business unit
to make sure that we can
get the right boxes checked
for everything that
they want to do.
But we've gotten to this nice
fully automated pipeline that's
proved fairly resilient when
we've gone through updates
of everything, as we continue
to expand and improve
the environment.
And this has been a
combination of some
of the internally developed
packages within the Janssen
team, focusing on some of
their environmental workflows,
as well as the other
packages that are
in use within the environment.
So there's been a lot of
different components of this
that have come together to
make this a focused product
for the team to deploy within
their space environment.
Thanks, Mike.
I want to jump over to some
of the Slido questions,
too, to make sure we get to
some of those anonymous ones
over there.
And one from
earlier was, Satish,
as data scientists and
statisticians request support
for open source tools, that
are new to their organization,
how do you think about this?
So thinking through tech
data or other issues,
they're trying to understand
your IT's perspective
from the requests
that you receive.
So yes.
So one, there is a
fairly easy part of it.
That is, what do
you need this for?
Why do you need it?
And that's a simpler question,
because there will always
be a convincing
argument from the users.
Where they'll say, I need it to
solve this particular problem.
However, the other part of it
is, as I mentioned earlier,
we do have to go through
a security process.
Where some of
these build process
that I mentioned earlier,
where we go through it,
behind the scenes, they come
in and scan the container.
Where they trigger a
security validation
report to check for
vulnerabilities.
And then they will flag it.
If it's a showstopper,
we have to address it.
No questions asked.
We have to address it.
It could be a simple question
of installing a newer version
of the system dependency.
And if our validation
fails at that reason,
then we will somehow have to
ensure that all the checks
and balances are-- basically,
we pass all the checks.
So when a request for
a new tool comes in,
we also have to check with
our internal security team
to see if there are any--
if they have any concerns.
Most of the times, you
know, yeah, it's OK.
But sometimes, they
will alert us saying,
hey, do you know that there is
a vulnerability risk with it?
Here is the reason why we
are going to stop this.
Most often, they will
also suggest a workaround,
or to see how we
can address that.
But when a request for
a new tool comes in,
or when a new R
package comes in,
we have to go through
these security checks, just
to ensure that we
don't expose ourselves
for any vulnerability.
Yes, it is true.
Things are sitting
behind a firewall.
Yes, it is true.
They are all running
inside a container, where
the chances are a lot
less than when it runs
in a traditional data center.
But we do have to ensure that we
comply with all of the security
risks and challenges.
Thank you very much.
I see, Alan, you have had asked
a question in the chat too.
Do you to jump in next?
Sure.
Yeah, hi, Satish.
This is really interesting.
And I haven't been working
with our clinical team
for a number of years.
So I'm a little bit distant
from the sort of state
of the art of that operation.
But a lot of my
experience at the time
had to do with just having
credibility with our SQA
and regulatory teams to--
for credibility, to work
them through a comfort
level with supporting
what we were doing.
And I wonder if you could
speak a little bit to,
what did that take?
Between the IT team, the
clinical team, the users,
to bring them along to these
new tools and platforms?
I've got to think that there
was a lot of change management
there.
And I'm wondering if there were
any sort of critical things
that made the difference for
you to get regulatory on board
with saying, OK, we're
comfortable speaking
to these systems in
an audit, for example.
So let me see how I can--
There's a lot there, yeah.
Any parts of it would be great.
Yeah, so you mentioned
users, and I also mentioned--
and I think you mentioned
regulatory agencies, as well.
As far as regulate-- and then
our internal validation team,
the TQ team, all
of that, let me see
if I can address that in
bits and pieces of that.
One, the users, they
were on board with it.
Because, number
one, as I said, they
would also want to learn from
others' experience, as well.
Mike mentioned the internally
developed R packages.
So they are also contributing
to the open source,
as well, at this time.
So there is both
a give and take.
Learn from each other.
So for the users,
it was pretty easy,
and they were the ones who
were saying, hey, we want this,
because this is going to help
us get to where we want, simply
because of the open
source contribution
and because things were much
faster when it came to R.
When it came to the TQ team R,
internal quality team, number
one, they wanted
to ensure, one, we
were basically putting a
checkmark against everything
that they asked for.
This was new for them.
We had to sit with them.
For example, the
dockable process
that I mentioned earlier,
they had several questions.
We had to prove it to
them that, no matter
what, what I run today,
if I have to come back
and run it again tomorrow,
except for the timestamp
that it was built, we
had to show and prove
that it was going
through the same process.
No matter how many
times we rebuild,
we were going to get
the exact same result.
Yes, there will be some
challenges along the way.
It wasn't easy, because
we were also new to it.
But we were able to
prove it to them.
And it required many--
I want to say weeks,
months of effort,
trying to convince them.
Because again, sometimes
when you are in the vanguard,
the onus is on you to prove
that what you are doing
is not violating any norms,
well-established norms
and practices.
So it took us some time.
So once they were convinced
that the tools and technologies
that we had used conformed
to their requirements,
they gave their
seal of approval.
Because they were also
learning in this process.
Because again, with
cloud technology,
sometimes they'll ask
questions like, hey, what
is your fail back mechanism?
What happens if things go down?
And as I mentioned
earlier, we are all on AWS.
So we had to tell them,
you have the power of AWS.
We wouldn't want to worry about
something going down or having
catastrophic-- but yet,
we had to plan for it.
Right?
We had to plan for it.
And then even something
as simple as disaster
and recovery, right?
How do you recover from it?
It's not like you could go and
build something immediately
in another data center.
Because we are locked on
to a particular AWS region,
which is US [INAUDIBLE] One that
is extremely popular for most
of the folks out here.
[? USC1 ?] Northern
Virginia region.
So we had to basically
convince them
that, yes, there are
some well-founded fears.
But no, we don't have to be
totally paranoid about it.
The question about the
health regulatory agencies,
and how did we
convince them, I'm
going to answer this in
a slightly different way.
If you talk to any
health agency as such,
they're not going to say you
have to restrict yourself
to R or SaaS, or this
is bad, or that is good,
or that is better.
We just have to prove it to
them that what we ran, whenever,
when they come and
ask you for evidence,
that we will be able to
show the exact same results
or the exact same study.
And let me stop here.
Because I don't have any
particular experience
with that part of it.
Got it.
Yeah, thanks.
No, I really appreciate
hearing that.
I think it's impressive.
Both really enjoy hearing
about the technological pieces,
but also about how the
organization got there.
I think it's pretty impressive
that the quality and reg
folks have got on
board and you've
been able to wrap that in
all the appropriate change
control and quality process
stuff that they require.
So yeah, it's neat
to hear all this.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Thank you for all the great
questions coming in too.
I see [? Parth. ?] You had
asked a question earlier.
Do you want to jump in?
The question was, is
R capable of running
production environments with
large scale data pipelines?
Do you test that capability
while validating a system?
Large scale, right?
So large is probably going to be
a relative term here, Rachael.
Many a time, we are going
to rely on our users
to tell us what that is.
Yes, we did see some
challenges initially.
And we are working
through that at this time.
Because there might
be an odd scenario
that we want to ensure that the
maximum load can be supported.
We are working with, as
you know, with Posit team
as well to help us with that.
And I feel very
positive that we should
be able to address some
of those issues as well.
Because at the end of the
day, these requirements
will have to come
in from our users.
And they will define
that we want to ensure--
I'm going to throw
out a number--
that 100 users concurrently
at the same time, or 400
as the case may be here, or 500.
We want to be in a
position to support that.
Sometimes, as you
know, folks who
are familiar with
EKS [INAUDIBLE]
we start scaling up,
there are some delays.
It could lead to
some frustration
on the users, where, instead
of seeing things respond
in a second or two, if
it takes even 30 seconds,
30 seconds is way
too much for them.
What can we do to
help alleviate that?
There are certain
tools and technologies
that we are still
evaluating at this time.
And for those of
you folks who are
completely familiar
and comfortable
with EKS, Carpenter, to
help us with auto scaling.
That is something that we
are evaluating at this time.
Again, as I said,
everything has to be
blessed from our
security team, and
from our internal
compliance team as well.
Because even if we
have to implement
what might be regarded as a
small change on the platform,
because these are what I
consider validated platforms,
there is extensive scrutiny
that we are subjected to.
Mainly in terms
of documentation.
Sometimes, it takes a little
longer than we would want.
For example, we
could deploy things
in our development environment
where it's pretty much open.
We can go and evaluate whatever
we want, implement it there,
and then we will
find out, oh my gosh,
it took us only two
minutes to do this,
but it is going to
take a couple of hours,
simply because we
have to provide proof
at each and every step, so that
if we have to replicate this
at a later time, we have all
of those protocols in place.
So yeah, it will take a little
bit longer to get there.
But that is one challenge
that we have today.
Thank you.
One of the Slido questions-- and
I know we touched a bit already
on the collaboration that
happens between teams,
especially with security--
but do you have any tips
about working internally
with your peers and
leadership to invest in moving
towards new platforms?
Yes.
One of the things that we
have to be cognizant of
is the cost aspect of it, right?
When we do things in
the cloud in [? One, ?]
we absolutely need to have
our leadership's support.
That is because with
in-house data centers,
with in-house equipment,
there is a finite cost
that is associated
with it, whether it
is the initial capital cost
or the maintenance cost of it.
We know what it is, and we
can always project that.
The challenge with AWS, or
with any of the cloud service
providers--
I want to say cloud provider--
is you cannot predict those
charges upfront.
Because you generally tend
to pay after the fact.
So I could-- for
example, the load testing
that we talked about earlier.
How much can we go and how
much loads can we test?
If we have to start testing,
then we will automatically
start scaling up.
We won't realize it.
And then at the end of the
month when we are handed a bill,
and we're like, what?
Did I incur so much of cost?
They don't tell us
here the reason why.
That is a unique challenge.
But on the other side of it,
consider a post-COVID world
where we were completely
shielded because none of us
ever came to a
[? Janssen ?] location.
We were prepping this remote.
We were 100% functional.
And all of that was because
we were in the cloud.
So there are certain
benefits, as well.
The cost part of it, you have
to have management support.
The huge advantage
with that is now,
hey, something happened with the
instance in your data center.
Somebody has to go
and physically verify
whether it is pulling out
a hard disk, replacing it.
All of that would cause
substantial delays.
With any of the cloud providers,
you don't have that challenge.
Something happened,
you stop that.
You start it back up.
Because that gives
you all the tools
to be back up and
running in no time.
So I see there's a
conversation happening
in the chat here, and
I can't really read it.
But I know it started
off Mike's question.
So Mike, I'd love to
have you asked that too.
Thanks.
Satish, thanks.
It's nice to hear about
another big pharma
company using containers and
the qualification process.
I've been at the sharp end
of that for many years.
And from my perspective,
it's fantastic to be
able to qualify at once and
then deploy it and use it
in many, many places.
It's one of the big
strengths of this approach.
But how do you
balance up the kind
of slow and steady approach,
of qualification, deployment,
keeping things
nice and, you know,
documented, and nice and
steady, versus colleagues
who want latest greatest,
give me it tomorrow, I've
got an urgent deadline?
Yeah, so let me talk about
from a validated platform
perspective.
Because I think it's relevant.
Yes, we do get
asked that question.
For example, for one of
the more recent studies,
it did require us to
install a newer version--
new package, which required
some system dependencies.
And there is no
instantaneous answer.
That's sadly-- you know, when
you have to containerize,
you have to balance your
long term prospects,
saying that, yes, there
is a short term pain,
but there is a long term gain.
And yes, it does frustrate
our users sometimes,
because we will not be
able to react to it simply
because, again, when you go
through this build process,
you will encounter challenges.
Trust me.
But where I see a
silver lining is,
we have incredible
partners, both from Posit
as well as [? Atoris, ?]
who are helping
Janssen with that approach.
Right?
So any time we have a
challenge-- for example,
when we deployed
our Workbench, we--
due to the nature of--
every organization
will have their own unique
challenges, I promise you that.
Every organization.
One of the things that we
had internally debugged
was how we were treating
our clinical data in terms
of active directory groups.
A little bit more tactical.
But when we realized that the
initial deployment of Workbench
did not work out, they were
able to quickly come up
with a release and then come
up with an update saying,
here is how we are going
to help you get that.
So we were able to
deploy a new version.
There it wasn't a
question of "if,"
it was a question of "when."
We wanted, and we were able
to, adopt that quickly--
fairly quickly.
But then the process that
it takes to get there,
documenting each
and every thing,
that there is no shortcut.
I'm afraid there's
absolutely no shortcut.
Because our TQ team wants proof
that, hey, show us evidence
that what you did.
So there's extensive IQ, OQ
that we go through, as well.
Yeah.
There is absolutely no shortcut.
But we always have to tell what
is right, do the right thing,
as everybody says.
Saying that, yes, there
is a short term pain,
but there is a long
term gain there.
I would also just
add that there's
a completely separate business
unit consideration for this,
as well.
Because Mike, with
you at Pfizer,
you're also another
group that has
a large group of SaaS users.
And the target group that this
is going out to in Janssen
is that SaaS business unit.
So, Satish is just one part
of this R adoption effort
that goes into the
packages that are--
[INAUDIBLE] was just
released open source.
But that was designed
to be able to support
Janssen standards to be
able to live up to all
of that within that group.
But then you have all
of these business users
who have gone
through SaaS training
to get on board with that.
And if you start changing
everything underfoot
without bringing them
along with you too quickly,
then that will also
upset the business users
in a different way.
So there's definitely
a balance to strike
that you need to consider from
an organizational standpoint.
Yeah, see-- sorry, go ahead.
I think the kind of folks
involved in reporting clinical
trials data want it to be
nice, controlled, well-managed,
slow changing, predictable.
It's other groups who have
more rapid turnaround--
the statisticians,
in some senses,
supporting those
groups, that want
the kind of latest greatest.
This just emerged
on [INAUDIBLE]..
Now I want it because
it solves my problem.
But I think, like
Satish is saying,
that the process
to just simply fold
that into the
existing framework,
it's not as simple
as many people think.
So I'm agreeing.
Yeah.
It never is.
It will take some
time to get us there.
But the one thing that the users
absolutely want is stability.
We don't want to introduce
changes which will potentially
break things.
So that's a red flag.
That's a no no.
And this is where we spend
a careful amount of time,
a substantial amount
of time, ensuring
that care is given to ensuring
backward compatibility.
We don't break things.
And this all, at
the end of the day,
will depend on how much of IQ,
OQ are willing to go through.
How much of effort we
are going to put into it.
And I think it is well worth it.
I'm getting the feeling that
this is a topic we definitely
want to stay on.
There's a lot of
thoughts on here too.
I see, Eric, I think you added
in-- you said you had something
to comment on here, too.
You want to jump in?
Yeah, I had a few of them.
But I think the key points
that I was commenting on
are that containerization,
we're looking
at this from kind of
the broader level,
for an organization's
analytical platform.
I'm interested,
Satish, if you've
been keeping an eye on things
like GitHub code spaces,
where it's giving, at
a repository level,
the ability to containerize
its environment.
I mean, you can do that
without GitHub code space,
as well, I suppose.
But I'm just curious
where you find--
where your opinion is on
maybe those other analysts
or statisticians that
want to be on the cutting
edge for a particular
project, and they
try to take matters in their
own hands, if they have a little
know how of how containers
work with Docker and the like,
compared to what
you're trying to do
from this more broader
effort, which is obviously
hugely valuable too.
Yeah.
One thing that I must
have forgotten to mention
is, even with the containers
that internally get deployed,
our technology services
team will tell us
what we could use
as a base, right?
In other words, we just cannot
go and pull anything from
Docker hub.
It has to be validated again.
Because they want
to do a scan of it.
So there are some, I want to
say, well-defined requirements.
I don't want to
call it constraints.
It could be as
simple as, you have
to use this version of
[INAUDIBLE] containers.
I'm just throwing
out as an example.
You can't simply
go and use Ubuntu
unless it is supported
inside our J&amp;J ecosystem.
That is, I'm sure folks are
familiar with Artifactory.
Artifactory is where we
host our container images
and where we also pull
certain base images as well.
So to answer your
question, Eric,
we cannot go and pull
directly from GitHub.
But to answer a
second part of it--
say, for example, if you were
to point me to some GitHub repo,
can you support this?
The short answer is maybe.
And The reason I said
maybe is we can go and take
a look into it, see what
software modules are
being installed as a
part of it towards--
in the container.
See what it is that we
could immediately use.
Or if it requires some sort
of a substitution by-- say,
for example, some other
equivalent package--
then we will go and
download it, install it.
All of that, so long as it
is blessed by our technology
services team, we'll
be able to do it.
So the same challenge exists
for our users as well.
They have to rely on somebody
in IT to help build them that.
Yes, we are deploying pipelines.
For example, Mike referred
to the internally developed
package as well.
We are now
establishing pipelines
where users, from the business
partners that we work with,
can develop a mod package.
And by simply doing the cut and
paste of the basic necessities
of the pipeline.
We use Jenkins pipeline.
We call it Jenkins
Pipeline Manager.
So they'll take that part
of the infrastructure code,
replicate it, and
then work on what
they are best qualified to do.
That is, work on the
art package and not
have to worry about the
mundane aspects of, oh,
how do I build it?
How do mint it?
Because all of that is
streamlined to a point
where we run through the
limiting, unit testing process.
All of [INAUDIBLE] in an
art package is being built.
So we help them by deploying
those pipelines as well.
So we make it sort
of easier on them,
but sometimes I might
be trivializing things.
Some users might find
it a little bit more
challenging for their test.
But we are trying to templatize
it to minimize disruption
to the users.
To minimize learnings
for our users.
Because that's
infrastructure, right?
I mean, they might
be focused more
on clinical trial
reporting efforts
than have to worry about
mundane activities like, oh,
how do I build this?
Because that's IT.
Thank you.
That's very helpful.
And I consider myself one
of maybe four or five people
in my entire
organization that likes
both sides of that spectrum.
But we can't expect
all the statistician
to be as geeky about
this as people like me.
Yeah.
Nick, I see you had a great
comment on building adoption.
And I'd love to spend a few
minutes talking about that too
if you want to jump in.
Sure.
Is there a specific question?
Well, no, I just
saw you were talking
about educating the users
about validation, as well.
Right, yeah.
Yeah, this goes back to
Mike's question around,
how do you deal with validated
versus having the latest
greatest?
Yeah, I just threw
in my two cents.
I think the big part from
our side is really education.
So I guess [INAUDIBLE]
kind of mentioned,
as well, a lot of the
users don't really care.
But you have to help them
understand this is difficult,
right?
It's not just, I want
this, let's have it.
We have to consider accuracy,
reproducibility, traceability
of these things.
Most important is that
our results are correct.
And they understand that, right?
So that's kind of what we
used to make sure like,
OK, we have to validate this.
Here's what it takes to do it.
It's significant effort.
So that takes a little time.
But then really use case driven.
So sometimes people
ask for things
just because they want them.
But then when you said, well,
what do you want to use it for?
You start getting more details
that they don't really need it.
So having that use case driven
validation-- what do you
need it for?
Why do you need it?
Is it for production
or is it something
you could just use as like an
exploratory environment, right?
Do we really have
to validate this?
And that really shortens
the list a lot more.
And then once we get to,
OK, we get it, you need it,
we don't have the expertise
as like the team that's
overseeing it.
You're now sort of our
de facto expert on this.
Put some skin in the game.
Help us out with this.
And then, sometimes,
they're willing to do it.
Versus maybe they
say, well I see
you've already validated
the-- the stats
package is approved for use.
I could do the stats
package instead.
Let me just use that, you know?
And it sort of helps again
shorten that list out.
Thank you.
That's really helpful.
Sure thing.
Travis, I realize I had missed
a question of yours earlier,
and I wanted to have you jump
in next with your question.
Did I ask a question
that wasn't answered?
I think you did.
So it was earlier
when I missed it.
But it was about, are
there any open source IQ
[? OQ ?] pipelines for R?
Oh yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Mike had some
good commentary
in the chat around that too.
Yeah, because I
mean I guess sort
of the source of
my question was,
for many use cases in clinical
research like we're doing,
it would seem that the IQ, OQ
need not be overly complicated.
Because if we just want to
ensure that R was properly
installed and can run,
[INAUDIBLE] pipelines, can run
a regression, a time-to-event
analysis without trouble.
We're not doing anything fancy.
It would seem, couldn't I just
do some minimal set of checks?
For which someone might write
a reasonable starting point?
In the open source
realm for like,
has R actually
properly installed?
And does it actually-- do
these three, four packages
do the thing that
they're supposed to do?
Just curious about what a
minimum viable product for that
might look like.
But this is, of course,
a [? Atoris' ?] realm
of expertise.
So I really don't know what
those answers would look like.
Yeah, and just a note, one
of the things that we've really
taken the guidance
from is the work
that was done in
the R validation hub
to start defining what a risk
based approach to validation
is around that.
And for things like
a lot of the base R
stuff, a lot of the tidyverse
maintained packages,
those are--
Nick, what is the term
that we landed on--
accepted for that, where you
can run the package unit tests
and you can accept that?
But again, part of this is
also documenting the evidence.
But that was done so
that you can pass those
through Satish's team, get the
report so that we can log that
into the QA systems, so
that you have the evidence
and traceability
that that was done.
But then, like Nick says, when
you get into other things,
and especially getting into
the more statistical realm
of things, having use
case driven approaches
around what you're
looking for, how you can
defend the integrity of that.
And then, my
comment back to you,
you're saying that it works.
What does work mean?
What is the kind of baseline
that you're assessing that
against?
So there's a lot of
questions that you
need to go in and investigate
and answer that so that you're
defending yourself.
Because all of
this comes back to,
what happens if you have
to undergo an audit?
What if a regulatory
agency comes back to you
and then starts asking
questions of how you're
verifying what you're doing?
So that's the worst
case scenario,
and something like this
would be that there--
something is turned around
because the integrity
of your system was questioned.
And pharma, I think that
a lot of times pharma
is extremely risk averse, just
because of the investment that
goes into getting
where things are.
Statistical programming has
an extremely small window
in the larger scope of
everything that's going on.
And no one wants to be
the person who kind of is
the showstopper for something.
Or even delays can just
be extremely costly.
But yeah, we're working in an
extremely risk averse industry.
That's a fascinating
answer, especially regarding
the unit test for that.
I mean, it hadn't
occurred to me.
But it's probably a good
message to developers.
Write good unit tests,
and then there's
actually almost
unintended but fortunate
downstream consequences of
writing good unit tests.
So you could just
write out that report
that, for example,
the Tidyverse Unit
tests, which I know are
comprehensive and good,
check out.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
And one of the things that at
least our technology services
team is pushing for is to
ensure that every R package goes
through some static analysis.
Saying, OK, here's
what's being deployed.
Did it go through all
the checks and balances?
Sometimes it's impossible and
sometimes it's not possible.
And it depends on who
you are talking to.
For the users, does it work
for my particular use case?
Go deploy the package.
Somebody else comes
in later and finds out
that it's causing a conflict.
That's a red flag.
Sometimes, security might
only be looking at it
from a slightly
different perspective.
They don't care about
the functionality.
They care about the
security aspect of it.
So if it passes all the
vulnerabilities checks,
then you are good to go
from their perspective.
But go back to this comment that
you had earlier, Travis, that,
hey, I just installed it.
Did it work?
I'm going to go and use it.
There is a danger,
as Mike pointed out.
I've personally seen
one effort, at least--
I don't want to say it failed.
But it has reached
a point where nobody
wants to use this because IT
took this approach that, yeah,
we're going to build this,
gonna do minimal qualification.
For us, if it installed R, good.
It passed our check.
Then they said, it's on the
users, like Nick and others,
to go install the R
packages for what they want.
And then they suddenly
realize that, as everybody
knows in the R ecosystem,
most of the packages
are users can install.
There is this small subset
that is-- sometimes,
it requires a unique
dependency, which is easy.
But sometimes it does
require things to be handled.
And that's where the users say,
I don't have this expertise,
and I'm sorry, I
just cannot use this.
So there is a danger to it when
you do minimum qualification.
I for one certainly
don't believe in it
and wouldn't encourage that.
We have to take our
users' workflow,
ensure that everything
is tested accurately.
As Mike pointed out,
it's just to make sure
that we defend ourselves.
God forbid if there
is an audit and we
have to show evidence of what
we ran a couple of years ago.
Trust me, that short term pain
leading to long term gain,
it's accurate in this place.
Thank you, Satish.
I know we have a few minutes
until the top of the hour here.
Walter, I see you had asked
a question a few minutes ago.
Do you want to jump
in and ask that?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah, I can hear you.
Right.
No, I was just curious
because I understand
that the versioning and the
environment and everything
for, let's say,
critical packages,
or critical tests that
are maybe developed
and deployment packages,
need to be in place.
But I'm working in
the finance industry.
And so we also have
architecture in place for,
let's say, less critical
like convenience packages.
And I just wanted to ask
if they are mixing these R,
using artifact with
maybe the package
mirror, internal package mirror,
for less critical packages,
like user convenience stuff.
And these things already take--
keep everything on the
Posit package manager.
Just out of curiosity,
because you mentioned
having Artifactory, having
Jenkins [INAUDIBLE] and things
like that.
Just [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
So we will not distinguish
whether a particular package is
less important or one is
more important, Walter.
We just don't take
that approach.
If a user wants a
package, we just
go through the entire
process of IQing, OQing.
Yes, it will be in
Posit package manager.
Yes, we will snapshot it.
We will use the exact same
snapshot to replicate it.
But no, we do not say, hey,
these are less important.
This is going to--
not go through any qualification
or any such thing like that.
We just go through
the totality of it.
And as Nick pointed out
earlier, the question
will always be, why do
you need this package?
And once that question
is answered, from an IT
perspective, it really doesn't
matter towards the importance
of that package.
Yeah, but I was just
curious, because as I said,
sometimes it makes sense to
put the full force behind it.
But sometimes if it's
just like some reporting
or some small shiny
dashboard that you
want to share with
colleagues internally,
it probably may be
overkill to have it
go through the whole process.
I was curious if you had
this approach, as well.
Because where I come
from, we have it.
That's why [INAUDIBLE].
It will be a little
bit hard to treat it
as a validated environment if we
haven't gone through the checks
and balance round.
And one more question
on packages, too.
I see Javier you had a question
going back to the containers?
Thanks, Rachael.
Yeah, and I'm sorry.
I've been in and out with
side conversations with work.
So my apologies if
this was covered.
But we have a
similar setup, where
we build containers and
have kind of snapshots
of RStudio Package Manager.
And as I guess one of
the heavier users of R,
at the company, something
that is not a big deal, just
a weekly annoyance, is that the
versions of the packages that
are loaded in these containers
are specific versions that
might have been snapped,
let's say, six months ago.
So the first thing I do
when I load my RStudio IDE,
which is in the cloud, is
to update the packages that
are persisting.
And then I install
additional packages
that I need for my workflow,
or [INAUDIBLE] app, et cetera.
So I was just
curious if you had--
it'd be excellent if the
packaged versions that
were kind of booted when
I loaded my RStudio would
be the current versions
of those packages
deemed for persistence.
And that's just something--
I don't know that there's a
better solution to what we
have right now.
I didn't know if there was
maybe a recommendation you had?
For a validated
environment, the short answer
is you just have to
rebuild the container.
Yeah.
And there's no
other alternative.
However, the process is, if you
need new versions of existing
packages, then you just
go through the basic IQ
OQ that was already
written for that package.
But if there's new functionality
that you want to adopt,
yes, you will have
to write new IQ OQs.
No questions asked.
But there is no shortcut here.
You just have to
repeat and rinse
through this entire process.
Got it.
OK.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Sure.
And we go through
this whenever we
have to build a new container
from an IT perspective, right?
We do check with
users like Nick first.
Hey, did it meet this?
Your requirement?
And they have their own
acceptance testing, as well.
Then he'll come back and
say, nope, something failed.
I need you to look into it.
Yes, it's in-- basically,
it's repeat and rinse.
Right?
So you go through this
process all over again.
So go back to the drawing
board, add the packaging,
add any system dependencies,
run through your IQ.
You've released
the container for--
in development
for users to test.
And once they say, yep, this all
looks good, it's at that time
we quote unquote
"lock" the container.
I know we just passed
the hour mark here.
And a few people had to
jump off for other meetings.
I just want to say thank
you so much, Satish,
for sharing your
experience with us.
And also the [? Atoris ?]
team for joining.
Satish, you are such
a wealth of knowledge,
and it's been great getting to
see more of the IT experience
as well that we don't
always get to talk about
in these hangouts.
Thank you so much.
My pleasure.
Thank you for having me.